there's been much hype for the new
ghostbusters sequel ghostbusters
afterlife and many fans can't wait till
it's released in 2021 with that said
hasbro has decided to release something
ahead of time so without further ado
this is the ghostbusters plasma series
spangler's neutrino wand by hasbro whew
that is a mouthful real not with this
ghostbusters plasma series bangles
neutron wand fans can pretend to suit up
as part of the ghostbusters team and
imagine blasting all sorts of
frightening phantasms and eerie
ectoplasmic entities premium design deco
leds authentic sound effects motorized
vibrations intensity adjustments stream
extension with up to four busting modes
and a display stand this neutron one is
so much fun
it's scary
[Music]
so let's get to the unboxing
so starting with the box this is
spengler's new channel wand
by hasbro it's the plasma series
and it requires three
double a batteries
very nice
ghostbusters logo here nice font and at
the back
there's a little bit of more details
about the neutrino one
with authentic sounds leds motor
vibrations it can extend the stream
there's four different modes
[Music]
and an intensity adjuster or just
intensity
it looks like an old steel chest
that we saw in the ghostbusters trailer
the ghostbusters afterlife trailer
and
a nice uh taped up
uh design with the word neutral not one
it's the whole design of the box it's
like an old um steel
okay so iron
chest
here it's all dusty and stuff
and let's open it
so this is what it looks like out of the
box
which you don't want here
the display stand a few instruction
manuals at the bottom
and
couplings
for the display stand
okay so let's take this out
got a pair construction manual
here
uh shows us how to install the batteries
the three double-a batteries how to
install the display stand
so yeah let's uh put the batteries in
get a display stand done and then we'll
go into the neutrino one awesome
so this is the new tuna wand
here we go
very nice design
i like the weather look and they even
got the
clipart
modules here which is awesome
right
very nice
very nice
okay
and of course
the display stand
so to install the battery all you need
to do is unscrew
the end of the cap
and
the battery pack
which requires three
double a batteries
and all you need to do is just put it
back in it will slot right in
and cap it
now the most brilliant thing that came
with it was an end cap
another end cap adapter
another end cap adapter which really
looks like
something you would put on a proton pack
so who knows
it says we're gonna release another
proton pack we're gonna screw up a hose
in here
that'll be awesome wouldn't it be
cool
so i know you guys want to get to the
good bits but what we're going to do now
is we're going to install the display
stand
[Music]
hey
awesome
so guys just from the look of it this
bad boy looks just as real as the ones
you see on the big screens
it has a
very cool
realistic paint job
very nice all the weathering the
weldings and stuff and even nice uh
rubber
kind of hand grip there
pretty cool
all right
and you've got the heatsinks
a nice heatsink over here
clipart
um detailing
even the knobs man knobs are turnable
stuff like that even got the danger
signs
some circuitry designs here these are
not rotatable though so yeah
another cool thing here is the base
plate and a hook
so if you are into role playing one
addresses the ghostbusters you can hook
this to your belt and this clip
kind of hints that there might be a
proton pack where you can hook it up so
very very interesting
you've got a nice uh looks like what it
came from a shotgun barrel it's a nice
grip
so
together it'll be like uh you know
you're gonna like blast some guys just
like that
it's not getting gun but
you know
pretty pretty awesome
the details on the wire
it's very nice
very very nice
so getting into the nitty-gritty details
of the neutrino wand let's turn this bad
boy on
click flick
and activate
alright
starting with the activation switch this
activates the event light
and we also have the intensify button
which
activates the barrel led
and also changes the sequencing pattern
of the power level indicator
all right so we also got this knob that
basically adjusts the intensity of the
beam so
see how it
changes
all right that's pretty cool
all right we also have the
barrel extension lever so if we were to
pop this boy
back
all right
and turn it back on
[Music]
very nice let's try that one more time
push that back
and
it extends
very very very cool
so activating this first and then
this main power switch would activate
all the gun lights as set for the event
light that we see here so we can
activate it again
this will be a flashing white led
a static orange led that we see over
here as well as a static red led over
here
we have a very cool flickering barrel
[Music]
very
nice and the coolest thing about it is
that when you hold it long enough
it will actually overheat
[Applause]
so we're getting there
[Music]
and when it overheats everything shuts
down so
you gotta flip everything back down
again
and turn it back on
right it's also a very cool vibration
coming from the gun itself
with the
if you increase the intensity of the gun
the vibration actually gets stronger
also as you intensify
really getting the vibrations there
so if i were to put it on the table
to probably hear the vibrations
[Music]
if i look this is our highest intensity
in the following
[Applause]
so very very very cool
top of that you got four different modes
before a single press of this button
it's a nice sound when it changes
like i said four different modes
first one is a classic proton stream
[Applause]
[Music]
the second one is a slime blower
[Applause]
all right cool
third one is a
status stream
[Applause]
and the fourth one is the misen collider
which has a pulsing effect
[Music]
very very cool
so getting to the sound
it is super loud thanks to a nice
um
speaker slot
over here
it's basically hidden behind the
heatsink
so it's very cool you can see it right
there
there we go and man the sounds are crisp
they are boomy and each sound effect
just sounds super awesome so let's uh
i'm just gonna keep quiet now and just
gonna hear what we can do with it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so one gripe about this
is that it's definitely for right-handed
people so the actual way of using this
will be
of course you activate it first
your right hand on the grid
and your thumb will be pressing on the
intensify switch your left hand will be
grabbing this so that you can change the
modes every time
if you wanted to
classic ghostbuster style
[Music]
and of course the display stand is not
really solid it does uh have bit of give
of course it's made out of plastic
but it does have a matching style that
really uh really suits the theme of
ghostbusters we even have a nice
ghostbusters logo over here you can
orient it any way you want if you want
it uh
if you want the stock
uh to be
raised up or
if you prefer
it the other way around
honestly i prefer it this way so so
that's the end of the unboxing the final
verdict should you get it
yeah dude if you are looking for the
ultimate cosplay or prop collectible
this is it with its impeccable detail
and high functionality this will make a
great option for your next halloween
costume however since it costs a little
bit more on the expensive side you might
want to put this on your display rather
than wearing it out so for what it's
worth you've got yourself a very neat
replica
and i have to say
hasbro has done an amazing job with this
and we can't wait for what's next in the
ghostbusters plasma series
so that's it guys thanks for watching
this video you guys know what to do give
us a like share do leave us a comment
down below and tell us what do you wish
for the ghostbusters plasma series also
if you haven't already do consider
subscribing and smash that notification
bell icon so you can see our latest
unboxings reviews and more geeky tidbits
until then this is zeki signing off
[Music]
you